welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is of shock Acharya an associate
professor and the Department of
Political Science and joint director of
developing countries Research Center at
the University of Delhi at Yale
professor Acharya is the Henry Hart Rice
foundation fellow at the Macmillan
Center he is author of the forthcoming
volume equality difference and group
writes the case of India professor
Acharya is research interests in compass
contemporary and comparative political
theory affirmative action and ethics and
public policy today we'll talk with him
about his project called know your
rights India
welcome professor Acharya thank you very
much that's a privilege so you are a
professor at the University of Delhi in
India why are you here at Yale as the
rice fellow well I was invited and you
know I thought I was just take up this
opportunity to be especially at Yale and
spend a year the invitation was pretty
exciting because it allowed me to work
with the Macmillan Center and especially
with the global justice program which is
where much of my current research
revolves around okay so let's talk about
your current project know your rights
India give us an overview of it know
your rights India is a project in its
infancy but this is a project that tries
to bring together on a wiki based
platform using online technologies
listing all the rights benefits and
teittleman's of all the people and
especially those that relate to the
needs and aspirations of the poor and
marginalized people of India and on one
single platform what we plan to do is
not only spit what all those rights are
of the people and the benefits are but
also sip you know give an account of a
simplified procedure of how to realize
those rights and it's not just about
literacy we also know that India doesn't
have full literacy that there is still a
substantial proportion of the people who
are illiterate what it would that
proportion there oh that would be
roughly around 40% would be illiterate
and so that's you know between 35 to 40%
and that's a huge number yes but when we
speak about the rights illiteracy per se
you know this this is a problem that we
see happening just anywhere it whether
you are literate or we are not literate
you know the rights and the language in
which those rights are expressed the
laws and the policies are not always
accessible to common people so people
have to struggle and that's why the
lawyers make a field day so what led you
to create this project what gave you the
idea well the idea was essentially to I
thought that we are right at a cusp in
India where we are foreseeing a
revolution of increasing recognition of
people social and economic rights so
there is a right to education you know
there is a right to employment and we
are soon debating you know very
seriously about the right to health
whereas I also felt that most of the
time and most of the people wouldn't
know what these rights are unless
somebody told them look these are your
entitlements and you can claim them and
that and and and and many of the NGOs
who work on the on this on these areas
are too specialized like you know there
are health NGOs and there are you know
livelihood related NGOs and they are
also you know geographically
concentrated in a few places so we felt
that if we have to build up in knowledge
community and through that empower the
people the best way to do is to build up
this the the the wiki based platform
which will not only educate people about
what the rights and entitlements are
the simplest of the language but also
bring in many of these NGOs and draw
them in into the network and through
them make them the interlocutors through
which we can speak to the common people
so it is about rights literacy campaign
sort of a rights education campaign
which also would need the help of the
NGOs right because as you had said
there's 35 to 40 percent of the country
is illiterate so they wouldn't
necessarily be able to read a website so
you would need that intermediary to work
with people absolutely absolutely
yes okay so what are the objectives well
the objectives are you know as I just
said you know the to build up a very
comprehensive website and in for each of
the right you know lead the person
through the various stages okay here is
your right in the most simplified
language and then if it is not realized
at this level you know you can take this
further up through this procedure so we
guide them step by step on every little
entitlement that they have and these can
vary by the way through across provinces
so different provinces would have
different ID teittleman's about how
there is to realize the power those
rights you know there are a set of
constitutional rights and there are
different sets of you know policy
entitlements that different provinces
would enact from time to time so is the
website in effect today could one go to
the website no it's not yet built up you
know we are we are not mobilizing all
our resources to build this up and when
it comes it will not be actually we
called know your rights it would be
called John a Dakar which means in Hindi
John means people and Alec are means
rights so people's rights okay so we
have registered the domain but we will
have to launch it right now at this
point of time we are collecting a lot of
data and especially at this stage we are
collecting data from four states and
India has many states you know 28 states
and so many union territories so we are
only collecting from four different
states geographically north south east
and west and in course of time we turn
this four different states into four
different nodal Jones so the northern
state
roxeanne for instance becomes the the
nodal zone for northern india and then
the eastern state of Orissa for instance
become the nodal zone for eastern India
and then they collect data from
neighboring states and and then amass
all of that okay so and you chose
Hindi because that's the most most
commonly spoken language that's roughly
forty percent of India's population
speaks Hindi though it is it is a it is
the it is a most spoken language in
India though there are other languages
and that's one of our father' challenges
that at the first step required
translate all the web content from
English to Hindi and then as a second
step we translate them into all the
other existing Indian languages as well
so more people have access to more
people have access so when do you think
it will launch oh that's a very very
tough question at this point of time
yeah we are we are we are trying our
best to have this launched as far as
their you know as soon as possible
but this means that you know working
closely with lots of institutions
educational institutions you know the
the law of faculties in the different
countries and I mean touch with some of
them to convert their legal clinics into
know your rights clinics as well as so
and I also want the content writing to
be done by the students so we have a
huge number of student interns working
on this and they have just begun the
work and only on these four states and
we hope that by end of July or August we
would be done with the work of these
four states after which we could
multiply and add the remainder of the
states and should be able to a
conservative estimate would be at least
you know two years from now and it could
be sooner you know I would be you know
but I'd be surprised if it is sooner
than that and once it is up and running
how you measure its success yeah that's
that's a very good question because
often enough we don't give enough you
know importance to this particular area
and so how do we measure
success and the the net behavior of any
net citizen you know is it's not always
very predictable people can suffer from
side to side so what we hope to be doing
is we measured the success of this on
the basis of three things of course the
first is very important is impact does
has it you know close the gap between
the between the level of people's
knowledge of what their formal
entitlements are and how they go about
realizing them so one of the ways of
measuring the success would be after a
given period of time if the if the rate
of benefits take up for any particular
right of some of the rights that are
highlighted in this website goes up then
we know we have had some success and but
that would be difficult to measure
because that would take a longer time in
the meantime we propose to you know do a
kind of a web analytics study on the on
the effectiveness of the content and use
some sample surveys to to measure as to
whether or not this is really appealed
to the people and whether they would
vote for it or whether they would
suggest certain alternatives to the
creation or the design of the of the
website and how they would what sorts of
suggestions they would give to improvise
the content of it and and the traffic so
the more number of hits of course we
mean we know that this is a success and
how would you how are you planning to
spread the word about the site so people
know about it this is this is something
we propose doing through the through the
educational institutions on the one hand
and also mostly through the NGOs whom we
are now trying to partner so I'd write
at this point of time what we have done
is we have almost successfully mapped
all the NGOs in the country Wow almost
all the NGOs in the thousands but we
have been able to map all of them and
now we are trying to
you know again categorize them as to how
effective they are in particular regions
and what are their areas of strength so
depending on which region which NGO
works in and what their areas of
strength we would further you know like
to open up an Avenue through which we
train even the NGOs to take up this task
at our behest because we can't be
reaching out everywhere sure right so we
will have to bring in the NGOs train
them and help them become the effective
interlocutors so so so the NGO mapping
has been one of the most challenging
exercises so far but it is still
something that you can do at home you
can surf the net and you can find out so
there's no central registry of NGOs in
India you know they get registered and
you have you know you can always get
information about these NGOs from the
different governments of the provinces
and the states but at times they can be
misleading also because you know many
organizations get registered and they
don't do anything right so there are the
there are the front organizations for
someone and so we want to find out not
only those organizations that are
registered but which are actually
working for the people and that's a
tough - and that's a tougher journey so
in which case we have to go through in a
step-by-step process so we not only do
we get the NGOs mapped but then we get
the entire info information vetted by
slightly bigger organizations and NGOs
which are in the business of funding
some of these local NGOs to find out
from them if you know we are right about
mapping out these NGOs as the effective
ones and whether they are really doing
the work in the in those areas seems
like a huge undertaking
it is ultimately what do you hope to
achieve with the project
oh very many things of course you know I
would say two things
primarily a I would say because of my
work on global justice and
I have become more sensitive to the and
then there's also a bunch of scholars
who are supporting me in this work back
in India we have become very sensitive
to the needs of the poor and the
marginalized so the first big goal that
I think we should be able to achieve is
still you have a better sense of how
this website is going to enhance the
livelihoods of people and that I think
would be a big achievement
the second big achievement I would say
is to create a knowledge community bring
academics in in closer contact with
activists and have a richer knowledge
community out there which then goes you
know goes out to strengthen our
démocratique experience enrich our
citizen engagement at different levels
and also somewhere pressurizes the
government to be more responsive to the
needs of the people and so we can you
know as academics we can keep theorizing
as to what makes democracy work but it's
it this would be a different kind of a
challenge to go out and see how do we
actually make democracy work very good
well thank you so much for being here
with us today and I wish you all the
best with the project oh thank you so
much it's a real pleasure for more
information about Professor Acharya and
his research please visit our website at
Yale edu slash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale